hey Alba you're ready I just caught a
car to the airport yeah be right there
all right all right
got everything phone keys be right back
[Music]
the globe-trotting food hound and
youtuber Mike Chen has traveled
everywhere seeking out the best and most
unusual eats including burgers which
makes him the perfect companion to join
me on an epic international burger tour
here in NYC no passports needed we're
gonna learn how an American icon is
being reinvented by chefs from different
cultural backgrounds including a pita
master a long gauche expert and a sushi
legend let's go at sub hoodie Oh big fan
I'm a big fan of yours come on make food
happen I've been following your for your
journey across the globe for so long
you're an aficionado for more like Asian
food noodles dumplings but I know you
have a hot spot for burgers oh I know
you have that like love for the meat
cheese and bread man burgers might just
be a global comfort food it is
fascinating to me this is why I like a
lot of my videos like I go to the local
McDonald's you know I love that right
exploring their local menus and there's
always different yeah there's always
something really uniquely local about it
every country you go to I mean there's
kind of like an idea of like the classic
New York burger Minetta tavern dry-aged
caramelized onions and the beautiful bun
but to me what I love is is the
diversity of the city me too it's still
following the format of the classic
hamburger but rebuilding it and making
it their own that's right and today
we're gonna try some special burgers
made by you know three people three
different backgrounds three different
styles and international burger tour and
we don't need to travel for we're in our
own City sorry I'm just getting really
emotional right now let's do it
hello whoo chef how are you what we have
here look at that yes
toss tell us all about this burger so
it's about that burger okay I vented it
especially for New York when I realize
that the cold sandwich of the city is
the burger the process is very simple we
are taking a burger and then we are
putting it inside a protea pressure
machine and then where I was in it on
the planche adding the cheddar cheese
and folding because we want to create a
kind of pipe that when we shall put it
inside the pizza all this thing will go
direct into your nose when you are
eating it the PETA is leading you the
end of the things are on the same angle
Wow one of most amazing burgers I've
ever had in my life I'm not I'm not
oh my I love you okay Oh Thank You chef
thank you so much
I mean I'm it's it's weird it doesn't
even look like a burger I can't even I
can say calling it a burger is is weird
for me but when you take a bite that's
the burger burger this might just be
what I've been looking for my whole life
this thing is all about balance every
single being here balance is something
else right we've got to shop pita
you've got to punch rust of the meat
into cheese look peppercorn a little
spice there the ratios are perfect the
yogurt when you bite into it
call it off smooth water yeah the
folding is ingenious because I never had
a burger I mean I had a burger where the
meat is almost like a bun so it's like
burger and stuff yeah right yeah dude
I've never had anything like this every
ounce of the juice is just wrapped right
into a bomb yeah that's your last bite
is waiting for your last bite it's like
the food is like the ending to forest
cover that's the greatest ever
you
this is my in-and-out moment oh gosh
putting the peppers on here whoa whoa
that was a spicy kick the bar is set
high so hot it's gonna be tough to beat
but we're on to the next burger man
let's go let's do it continue the severe
[Music]
Oh Thank You chef Maria well that's a
unique looking burger tell us all about
it we are a Slovak restaurant with the
Central European cuisine all our
customers kept asking for a burger and
we had a language in the house already
and it's a deep-fried flat breads that
served as a street food in Hungary
that's our bun
it's a half-pound patty that's first
grill on the grill has a mental cheese
bacon the homemade pickles homemade
mustard then you wrap it in the langars
dough and just throw it in the deep
fryer
all right so enjoy it thank you so much
thank you so much
they have like a perfect bite right
there that's different now Mike I've had
a bunch of burgers in my day this one is
particularly unique it's show skill it
shows the creativity of the chef also it
pays homage to you know where they're
from right that's what that's what we're
on this journey for yeah it's slightly
slightly flaking on the outside so
tender and airy on the inside this could
easily fail this could easily be too
greasy we're something we're cooked over
cut yeah right before I was cut open
right it's like a burger in this guy's
yeah it's like a bun yeah that's like
beef wellington you just have to like
take your phone out take a picture this
has that internet viral capability is
one of those viral hits that actually
tastes good
well you're the dumpling expert can this
be considered a dumpling this will be
the most meaty dumpling I've ever had
you opened my eyes to it's just what a
burger could because I was kind of stuck
in that hole like that's a burger it's
burgers but in whatever but just the way
that the buzz' transformed in the two
places we've winds you today eyes on
believable all right Mike I hope you're
still hungry always we're off to our
next burger by legendary Japanese chef
chef masa
I just dress up yes you join it Tatsu
burgers chef Marcel burgers chef masa is
doing burgers in Tribeca
let's get it
[Music]
chef masa how are you are you thanks for
having us
there's my good friend Mike baby that's
masa what a pleasure
I've admired your work my entire
culinary career and never in a million
years that I think that my first
conversation with you would be about
burgers great choice nothing my favorite
burger is always I can taste beef patty
cheese Ted sushi rice is how important
is right anyway yes and the piece of
coffee boring right yes the bond during
button yes and meat patty like a fish
important everyone in New York City
talks about this burger because of the
way it's made yeah I think so it's a
custom cast-iron skillet yeah actually I
designed that this is my hardest
cast-iron artist in the know love Japan
when I visit some other meeting then he
used ashtray perfect shape for and a
burger I was looking forward just I
asked him to make this two pieces next
to each other or jump with folding like
this I designed this for conveyor belt a
heating spot the Olo is the smokes well
it's supposed to be move up move away
it's a new definition of slider and
slides like they're all the way down
that's amazing
the beginning is just cast-iron we're
gonna hear it up I love it it looks like
a really great fats another 20% fat I
love it 3% then though there's a mixture
of the brisket no Chuck okay
this is this charcoal called pinch oh
yeah which is been joyous Obama which is
the hardest wood nothing exactly that's
why I love this now this is a little
seer Oh the sear on these things are
perfect those clothes
so that heat is on the spikes now and
the spikes are going through the booth
then throw the way excess fat look at
that
it's the fat hitting Nicole brings back
that flavor that I'm gonna consider I'm
married
gotta be worth picking up potato buns Oh
media oh this is the really interesting
part there's a smoker smoking chopsticks
yeah this job since we use before you
know masa which is little cedar I've
never had a smoked burger before expose
it oh that's it really so right now all
that smoke is fortifying that burger
smoking through it getting all that
flavor Oh perfect
sometimes we do people special people's
which was expecting something you know
different
we do a the chubby oh this is surf and
turf right here this is surf and turf
before him alone sold it's for me yeah
is oozing juice right out here cheers to
you cheers on the chef I need a martini
Oh perfectly stop I got you Kim let's
get the chef's some martinis
cheers cheers Cheers made my day
burger history baby I think this might
be one of the juiciest burgers I thought
about you Alvin the bun has so much
structure it holds everything together
you hold up juice don't need any
for middle layer of stuff yeah who needs
vegetables like I'm hitting some
pinnacle oh man no ketchup
I could see now having all these
elements in front of me how this burger
was birth and I thank you so much for
having us thank you that was amazing
they really opened my amazing shot at
giving my legendary burger from a
legendary shampoo thank you so much dude
if you're gonna make a good sushi you
can make good
[Music]
what's up burger fam it's Alvin kai-lan
from the burger show thank you for your
continual support make sure you hit that
like button smash that subscribe button
turn on your notifications if not for me
for the burgers please and thank you